good evening more changes could be
coming to the North End of the strip
thanks for staying with us here at 6 30.
I'm Denise Valdez and I'm Brian Loftis
after more than a decade of talks
surrounding it on that Arena Resort
scheduled now finally an opening date so
the property headed by former NBA player
that's Jackie Robinson would bring
another professional sports arena to
Clark County perhaps Sasha loft is
joining us now live from the proposed
site near Las Vegas Boulevard and Sahara
this is the open lot where all that is
set to go right between Fountain Blue
and Sahara on the North End of the strip
now the project has been in the works
since 2010 but those involved tell me
the funding is actually here now this is
a look at the renderings released today
it shows the 4.9 billion dollar project
that's set to tout a hotel sports and
entertainment Arena and a retail space
one thing the property will not have
gaming Jackie Robinson says this move is
important to create a new Vibe on the
North End of the Las Vegas Strip now the
important thing to note here those
behind this say funding is officially
secured County Commissioner tick
segerbloom backs the project and
Robinson says he has been working hard
to get investors on board here the
financing aspect looks like it's it's
it's it's there we've been trying he's
been trying to work on how to get in
finance for a long time in different
ways but but as far as I can tell and
talking to people out here in other
people places uh the money is there we
can do basketball boxing wrestling all
the other than usual but we want to
reach out and get other types of
situations that would come to us as for
sports and entertainment is concerned
another important thing mentioned the
possibility of an NBA expansion team
Robinson said well that isn't the main
driving force behind allnet it is
something he and others will push for he
also said he expects to bring 47 000 new
jobs to Clark County and hiring could
begin as soon as next summer that this
entire project as of now is set to wrap
up around the end of 2025. remember
reporting near the North End of the
strip Sasha Loftus 8 News Now